Yuriko, the Tiger's Shadow, is a pretty
unique card. It's the most popular Dimir
commander by a country mile. It's one of
only two creature-type based commanders
that sees common cEDH play, the other
being Magda, of course. And Yuriko does
not pay commander tax.
I guess if you're casting her for her
base cost, she does, but more
realistically, Yuriko almost always gets
cast for a commander ninjutsu cost,
which is forever pegged at two mana.
Last week, I talked about Eminence as
one of the two major exceptions to the
way commanders work, not even requiring
a commander to be on the board to have
an initial effect. And this is the
other, not costing additional mana for
subsequent commander casts. Yuriko, in
particular, has been singled out as a
design mistake, including by Gavin
Verhey, who worked on the original card.
And I agree with that assessment.
Commander ninjutsu is this bespoke
ability created with the one task of
bringing ninjutsu into the command zone.
And the fact that command tax wasn't a
part of that ability seems like an
obvious oversight in retrospect. The
results of this have bled into the
player experience, with Yuriko
commanding a similar salt score to that
of Edgar Markov, the most contentious of
the Eminence commanders. People are
bothered by this card, and they dread
playing against it. However, I think
it's interesting to dig into why Yuriko
is a problem for people, and how
important her tax evasion is in that
equation. Because I think the line for
not paying command tax is actually
blurrier than it seems, and more
sensitive to the specifics of a given
card, with Yuriko's other features being
equally important as her unique method
of entry in creating her infamous
status.
Broadly, there are two things that
contribute to Yuriko, in particular,
having a uniquely frustrating play
pattern for a lot of players, her vibes
and her power level.
By vibes, I mean that the way Yuriko
cheats commander tax feels uniquely bad
among commanders. And to demonstrate
that, we should talk about some other
tax evaders, and why they don't drum up
the same sort of ire. Firstly, let's
talk about the squeeze of the world,
legendary creatures that can be cast
from graveyard. On the surface, these
may seem similar to something like
Yuriko, since you can continue to cast
them for some fixed cost after they die.
But the comparison quickly falls apart.
Firstly, all but one of them will be
whisked back to the command zone by any
now commonplace exile-based removal. But
more importantly, they obey the rules of
60-card magic. These cards are designed
with the idea of them being cast over
and over, baked into the design. And
their function in a 60-card format will
be identical to their function in
commander after the first cast. The
uniquely potent thing about commander is
the command zone, and these are skipping
out on a large portion of the benefit of
that zone. One step up from these would
be Hogaak, a commander with the two
different discount keywords of convoke
and delve. Hogaak also shares being
castable from the graveyard with the
previous example, but perhaps more
relevantly, regardless of where the card
is being cast from, you won't be
spending mana. If it gets exiled a
couple times, the command zone cost will
go up accordingly, but paying in exiles
from graveyard or tapped creature tokens
will often feel much less meaningful
than paying in mana. You won't be
experiencing paying for Hogaak as a
linear barrier in the same way you would
with most other commanders. Nonetheless,
Hogaak still feels fine because its
payment method performs the gesture of
paying command tax. A big part of what
makes Yuriko frustrating is that it
feels like the Yuriko player is exempted
from a core rule of the commander
format. When other commanders get
removed, they're harder to cast, but
Yuriko simply isn't. Even if Hogaak
bucks some of the conventional wisdom,
it still doesn't feel like a major
outlier because you're still expending
additional resources.
This idea comes into even sharper focus
when we consider Liesa. Liesa, Shroud of
Dusk, is a five-mana commander who,
instead of requiring two more mana for
each subsequent command zone cast,
requires paying two life for each
previous cast. As a Liesa player, I will
tell you right now, that is not a
meaningful cost. In the 40-life format
of commander, most players are plenty
willing to fork over three life in
exchange for one mana. And two life for
one mana, as seen in something like a
Phyrexian mana symbol or an untapped
shockland, is pretty much a no-brainer.
Cutting that no-brainer rate in half,
one life for one mana, makes it
basically free and will rarely feel even
a little bit relevant. So, why doesn't
Liesa come to mind as a chronic tax
evader? The answer, along with other
factors we'll get to later, is the
gesture. If my Liesa dies, when I cast
her again, I adjust my life total by
down two numbers. If I need to cast her
again after that, four numbers. It's not
significant, but it's something, an
acknowledgement that my commander has
died, and this is not the first time I'm
casting her. I'm not playing by the
exact same rules as everyone else, but
I'm still playing the same format, and I
recognize the existence of that format's
rules. This brings me to an example
that, while less problematic than
Yuriko, is still a bit hairier than the
other ones I've mentioned so far,
Derevi.
She is a three-mana bant commander with
the ability to pay four mana to put her
from the command zone into play at
instant speed. This ability doesn't
perform the gesture, and it does kind of
totally cheat command tax. So, what
makes this different from Yuriko? This
is where the details get a bit more
granular. You could argue that four mana
is larger than three mana, so Derevi's
cost will usually go up at least once.
Though, it's not hard to imagine
somebody arguing that flash and
uncounterability mitigates this
difference, making the four-mana cast
option an appealing one in its own
right. To me, the more potent element is
the raw number. Four is a lot more than
two. Paying two mana for a commander
repeatedly is quite inherently powerful.
You hit the field early, and then
subsequent plays will leave boatloads of
mana open for follow-up plays or
counterspells or so on. By contrast,
paying four mana repeatedly for Derevi,
or five mana repeatedly for Liesa, feels
like more meaningful a cost. It's still
quite nice to have spare mana later in
the game when you're on seven or eight
lands, and not needing to worry about
having an uncastably expensive
commander, but that dynamic exists on a
decidedly lesser caliber than something
like Yuriko.
So far, I've been ignoring the text
boxes of all the cards I've been talking
about, which has its upsides in
isolating specific design elements.
However, now it's time to talk about the
other reason Yuriko feels so
frustrating, her power level.
What I mean by power level is simply how
much power you get based on the amount
of mana you pay. Yuriko's text box does
such a large amount for two mana that
it's almost absurd. The actual text
reads, "Whenever a ninja you control
deals combat damage to a player, reveal
the top card of your library and put it
into your hand. Each opponent loses life
equal to that card's mana value." If we
wanted to grossly simplify this, we
could replace this with the text,
"Whenever a ninja you control deals
combat damage to a player, draw a card
and each opponent loses two life."
Trying to find an equivalent card led to
Sisay, the Anointed, a six-mana Selesnya
commander who could realistically be
more like four mana given the niche
position of snakes, and Tovolar, a
three-mana wolf and werewolf commander
with a bit of added utility for flipping
werewolves, but no equivalent damage
ability. And Tovolar is a pretty good
tribal commander. A whole lot of tribes
would swoon at receiving that level of
utility from the command zone. So, we'll
say that Yuriko is along the lines of a
powerful three-mana commander or a
moderately powered four-mana commander,
and it's castable for two mana as many
times as you like, as long as you're
able to pay the ninjutsu cost. So, how
hard is that? Well, a quick visit to the
Yuriko EDHrec page makes that somewhat
clear. Ornithopter exists as an evasive
zero-cost creature that can get Yuriko
into play, and there are a ton of great
evasive one-mana creatures that can do
the same. Thousand-Faced Shadow,
Changeling Outcast, and Mothdust
Changeling are all also ninjas. And
there are other cards like Fairy Seer,
Siren Stormtamer, and Hope of Ghirapur
that have meaningful other upside with
Yuriko's game plan. The ninjutsu element
of commander ninjutsu decidedly is a
cost, but given that other ninjutsu
creatures also make use of these evasive
little dudes as well, it's hard to call
it too dramatic a cost.
By comparison, Derevi's untapping effect
for three-ish mana is far from bad, but
it doesn't give direct value or direct
damage, unlike Yuriko, which gives both
for two to three mana. Derevi is a good
commander, and you can do a lot of
things with her, but those things
require the convergence of other
elements of your deck. And it's
perfectly possible to stall out, even if
Derevi is generating you a lot of mana.
The power level point comes into even
sharper focus when we consider Liesa,
whose ability drains a player for two
life whenever they cast a spell. An
equivalent effect is on a pretty fairly
costed three-mana red enchantment called
Spellshock. So, for two extra mana,
we're slapping that on a 5/5 angel with
a couple keywords. The results is fine.
It's okay, an adequate overall package.
And Liesa commands a relatively modest
salt score of 0.8, even as a group slug
commander that effectively cheats
command tax. One interesting exercise
might be to imagine a world in which
Liesa drains players for four, or even
five, when they cast a spell instead.
That design wouldn't be overpowered
beyond the realm of possibility, but it
would be pushing toward the upper
reaches of what you might want to put on
a five-mana card. And for that reason, I
think that version of Liesa would be
absolutely despised, a monstrous
commander that players shudder in fear
thinking about. Barring counterspells,
the best case scenario there is your
opponent slams it down, you spend five
life and some mana to remove it, and
they spend some life to bring it back
out again the following turn, without
any commander tax. Nauseating stuff.
Obviously, this is more of a hardcore
group slug design, but nevertheless,
this is the sort of power territory
Yuriko lives in. We could alternatively
imagine if Yuriko had a commander
ninjutsu cost of four, [snorts] with
everything else about the card remaining
the same. It would remain a fairly
decent ninja's commander, still a more
powerful card than current Leisa, but it
would lose its status as an unstoppable
freight train of damage and value,
instead being costed similarly to a
coastal piracy plus a creature bounce.
This elucidates a weird quirk of the
commander format. Although it's a casual
format where power is modulated by
social factors and rule zero tools such
as the bracket system, power is still
strongly felt in how upsetting a card
design is. A lot of designs that are
unobjectionable now would become
extremely objectionable with a single
tweak, ala five Leisa, and plenty of
currently objectionable designs would
suddenly cease to be problems at all
with a nerf to their power level. This
power relationship can also be seen in
the salt scores that are compiled by EDH
Track by asking players how much they're
bothered by various cards, which I've
already referenced a couple times in
this video. The first couple dozen
saltliest cards all have some clear game
play reason for bothering opponents, but
what about Gaea's Cradle? What about
Necropotence? What about Mana Vault or
The Great Henge or Rhyming Throne? These
cards are purely proactive and none of
them do anything that unique, but they
just so happen to be at the highest
power level among all equivalent
options. So, they end up high in the
salt charts regardless.
This relates to fairness. [snorts]
Even in a casual format, there might be
a sense of something an opponent does
being unfair outside the bounds of ideal
game play. I'm not immune from this
either. I dislike the design of Rhystic
Study in Commander intrinsically for a
lot of reasons I'll probably get into in
a future video, and I also dislike
playing against it. Relevant to the
point here, would I dislike Rhystic
Study less if it was a five mana card
rather than a three mana one?
Yeah, I would. It wouldn't solve my core
gripes with the card, but it would
bother me less if it cost more mana. We
can kind of see how this concept of
fairness applies to Yuriko. A full
command tax cheater will garner some
baseline level of frustration for
opponents, and that frustration will
then be amplified depending on the power
level of the card it lives on, very high
in the case of Yuriko. So, what does all
this mean for the future? Should Wizards
of the Coast avoid cards with
alternative command tax structures or
should they print more of them?
My attitude here shares some
similarities with my attitude about
eminence cards in the sense that they're
both motivated by a sense of curiosity
and a spirit of play.
I like it when the mechanics of the EDH
format are tinkered with, utilized, and
recontextualized in ways that make for
interesting game play. I enjoy designs
that reference commanders and involve
the number of times a commander has been
cast from the command zone, both on
commanders themselves and on supporting
cards. I also like alternative costs
like the ones I've discussed earlier and
ways of interacting with command tax in
some way.
This choice of wording may hint at the
line I draw though, and that's that
commanders need to make the gesture.
They need to acknowledge in some form or
other that they exist within a format
where your commander costs more each
time it's redeployed. Hogaak and Leisa
both make the gesture, even if their
command tax feels insignificant at
times.
Partners make the gesture. Some will
argue that it's unfair that each partner
has a separate command tax, but how they
work with command tax is still an
acknowledgement of the mechanic and is
one interpretation of how it could
function with two commanders.
On the other hand, a big part of the
reason Derevi and especially Yuriko are
commonly disliked commanders is that
they don't make the gesture. Their
design totally ignores the existence of
command tax, and if you play either of
them, you don't even really need to
learn what command tax is.
My reasoning for why commanders should
acknowledge the existence of command tax
in some way is similar to the reasons
why I think eminence commanders should
feel incomplete if they go uncast.
Flirting with the mechanical borders of
the commander format is a lovely time,
but it creates a weird dynamic if the
design you end up with feels totally
outside those borders. It creates an
unfair feeling when three players are
following a set of rules that the other
player is totally exempt from. So,
that's one half of my design philosophy
here, and the other half is that for
cards like Leisa or Tasigur that make
the gesture but frequently feel
inconsequential in their casting cost,
it's important to keep in mind how the
card will feel with 100% uptime. The
current delve boys, Tasigur and Hogaak,
feel fine in this way with their most
powerful usages involving their mana
value rather than what they do if they
stick around on board. Leisa is likewise
fine, if anything a bit modest in terms
of power level.
The point here is just that cards that
are easier than normal to redeploy need
to keep that in mind with their design,
and that relates to both power level and
play pattern. If a commander is
disgustingly powerful, it's going to
feel especially unpleasant if it's
difficult to keep off the board.
Likewise, if a card is oppressive in
some way, making it hard for some other
decks to play the game, the feelings of
powerlessness it imbues onto those decks
will be amplified when conventional
methods of dealing with the commander
don't work very well.
I've enjoyed the feeling that my
opponents can't escape Leisa when I've
played with her in the past, and that is
a fun vibe to toy with, but it really
only works because her effect puts a
small tax on a plentiful resource, and
it's up to me to try and make that
plentiful resource scarce. It makes it a
little harder for me to critique Wizards
of the Coast when the biggest instance
of a de facto command tax cheater is
actually a really good design, but oh
well.
Be more like Leisa is what I'm saying, I
guess.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to
Architect for supporting the channel. In
preparation for an upcoming event, I've
done some light upgrading to my Mathas,
Fiend Seeker decks and some side grading
to my Radha deck, and it was easy to
keep things organized with Architect's
dual level category system. A link to my
decks is in the description if you want
to look at some of the tweaks I've made.
Speaking of upcoming events, I'm going
to be at LDX P Tacoma this coming
weekend, both enjoying Commandfest and
hopefully playing a bit of Riftbound as
well. Most of the convention is
available to attend for free, and I hope
to see you there.
Also, if you want to support what I do
on this channel, you can become a
YouTube member or subscribe to my
Patreon, and you'll be joining the
lovely people you see on screen now and
more.
All right, that's all for this one.